Ukraine is
now investigating
these gruesome beheadings.
Talk a little bit
about how you're doing that.
So, unfortunately,
this is not the first atrocities
which Russian army made in Ukraine.
Unfortunately,
we can see many atrocities at all
its doors and of thousands
atrocities and war crimes in Ukraine.
So we ask for justice and we ask that
no one leader don't stay
in the back
or in the other side
of these atrocities and support and
bring this war crimes
to the responsibility.
Have you seen these kinds of beheadings
of Ukrainian soldiers,
supposedly by Russian troops in the past?
We can see other atrocities
and they cut other parts of the bodies.
Our soldiers kill them after this.
And just killings of prisoners of war
In many ways, it's war crimes.
And this international court
is now investigating,
investigating all of these cases.
And security services
of Ukraine also investigate
all of these cases.
And I am sure that we will find and
bring to the responsibility
all of this war crimes.
And the main issue
is to bring to the responsibility
of this politicians, including Putin,
who made a crime of aggression.
So how much responsibility
do you believe Putin himself
has for these kinds of atrocities?
How much what do we mean?
Do you believe that Putin himself
is responsible?
Absolutely.
He is responsible for
a crime of aggression.
So he made
this order to go into a head
on the Ukrainian territory
and made all of these crimes,
war crimes,
which the Russian army made in Ukraine
and is making right now
on Ukrainian territory.
You consider these work war crimes?
Absolutely. It's crimes against humanity.
And from my side,
I estimate this like a heinous
hand of
side of Ukrainian people
because they kill
not just
prisoners of war, not just a Ukrainian
military service,
but they kill civilians.
Many children,
more than
a thousand children
are killed by Russians in different ways.
Not just
I know you're here in Washington.
You had a chance earlier today
to meet with the defense
secretary, Lloyd Austin.
There's a dispute going
on, I understand, right now
between the U.S.
and Ukraine over these leaked U.S.
intelligence documents,
which seem to suggest
that Ukraine was not moving
ahead, did not have a good chance
of winning this war again
that Russia launched against Ukraine.
How did that conversation
with the defense secretary go?
First of all, we discuss all our needs
because we are preparing
for our counteroffensive
and we work very closely
with our partners
and with
especially with the United States,
with the secretary of defense.
I'm really grateful
to secretary of defense for
strong and sustainable and unwavering
support of Ukraine.
And it's very important
that we are absolutely united
and no
special informational operations
will never destroy our unity in our will
to win this war
and to liberate territories of Ukraine.
And the main goal, to protect
civilized and democratic values
of the civilized world.
Is the leak of this U.S.
intelligence document
going to
change
your plans
for some sort of counteroffensive,
given what the U.S.
intelligence community
apparently believes? Absolutely.
We are preparing
and nothing will not stop us
and will not change our plans
to liberate our land.
I know you at least for a long time,
for weeks and weeks
have appealed
to the United States
for fighter jets, F-16s, among others.
Anything change on that front?
So very important
right now
we have
urgent needs for organization
of next stage of counteroffensive.
But in general,
we need a name of security guarantees.
We should develop our army.
We should develop and train our soldiers.
So it will take time. We discussed this.
What did the defense
secretary tell you about fighter jets
from the U.S.
going to Ukraine?
We discuss discussed
looks of our cooperation
with state secretary.
And I think that the last fourth is from
outside of United States of America.